Since we've now had a little bit of
practice with combining like terms, I want
to make sure that it's abundantly clear
which terms we're allowed to combine and
which ones we're not. Terms that you're
trying to add together can be combined if
and only if two things are true. So first
things first, the terms have to have
exactly the same variable or variables. So
examples of this will be terms like 3xy
and 7xy or -4b and 15b. On top of this I
have to add that each of these variables
that correspond to another have to have
the same powers or the same exponents. So,
if we have the term 3x^2 and the term 6x,
and we try to add those together, we
cannot combine them. These are not like
terms, even though they have x's in them,
this is 3x^2 and this is just 6x to the
first power. They don't have the same
power, so we can't squish them down into 1
term. Another example of this would be
something like 11ab^3 + 12a^2b3.
Even if the b^3 factors have the same
power, the a here only has a power of 1
and the a here has the power of 2.
We cannot add these two things together
because one of the variables involved
does not have the same power in both terms. So,
we cannot squish them down into one term.